bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi do io sono fa dj voglio soltanto
fare una piccolissima premessa allora il
videogame che state per vedere è in luce
un goss killer quindi il video game
incentrato sul famosissimo krypi pasta
di jack the killer questo video in
teoria non doveva uscire non sarebbe mai
dovuto uscire sul canale per il semplice
fatto che è troppo corto e uscito troppo
corto perché praticamente muoio sempre
non riesco mai a finirlo è se non dovevo
uscire come mai l'ho fatto uscire lo
stesso allora vi spiego
domani che venerdì uscirà un altro
episodio di scrive l'ansa limited epico
tra l'altro oltre ad happy wheels come
ogni weekend più precisamente sabato
uscirà il primo episodio di una delle
serie che avete votato di più sulla
pagina di facebook
se ancora non avete votato il sondaggio
siete comunque ancora in tempo il link
della pagina di facebook come in ogni
video nella descrizione e mi pare il
penultimo posto della pagina di facebook
e appunto sondaggio con tutti i
videogame che mi avete consigliato è uno
tra i più votati appunto inizierà sabato
ovviamente non me lo dico perché una
sorpresa e appunto per questo dato che
sabato deve uscire il primo episodio di
questa nuova serie deve uscire è più il
venerdì che domani deve uscire
scribblenauts oggi in teoria non avrei
dovuto mettere video ci sarebbe the
grudge ma ovviamente the grudge come voi
tutti sapete ci metto secoli a
registrarlo perché veramente richiede
molto più tempo di ogni altro l'ex play
che faccio quindi state tranquilli che
arriva è soltanto ci mette più tempo
quindi oggi raga non avrei dovuto
caricare nulla piuttosto che a non
caricare niente anche se questo video
non lo volevo caricare ho deciso di
caricare lo stesso quindi la gala
premessa è stata fatta più che altro
perché i video è corto e mi volevo
scusare per questo ma diciamo è soltanto
un caso però oggi piuttosto che non
caricare nulla ho preferito mettere
questo appunto quindi ragazze potete per
oggi chiudete un occhio ma state
tranquilli che ne vale la pena per tutti
i prossimi video che usciranno che
saranno epici a mio parere
indaga dovrei avervi detto tutto scusate
la premessa è
e niente vi lascio a di luzon gas killer
tenetevi pronti 321 bella a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
io sono parigi oggi siamo su illusion
ghost killer allora la gam e l'avete
consigliato veramente in tantissimi
nell'ultima settimana
premetto che lo hanno già fatto diversi
youtubers comunque su youtube in
generale è quindi in teoria non l'avrei
fatto perché l'hanno già fatto in tanti
ma dato che state continuando a
consigliarmi hanno ancora allora ho
deciso di farlo lo stesso allora
facciamo play this is a place fu lo
strange things many people
ok va bene faccio che tradurre molte
persone hanno sentito delle cose strane
delle sue strane di questo è vabbè dai
la mia un po meno tempo magari vabbè ci
sono delle voci strane su questo posto
piazza sei telecamere nelle aree
contrassegnate il rosso key che bella
siamo partiti allora vi dico subito
prima di iniziare veramente a giocare
seriamente il diciamo il cattivo tra
virgolette di luzon gas killer e jack
the killer che a me piace chiamarlo
gigio perché un nome prosismo jack the
killer è un clip ipasta che tipo non è
tipo slider però diciamo è un assassino
vabbè se volete leggetevi creevy pasta
basta che scrivete su internet crisi
pasta jeff the killer
eh vabbè il mio gigetto qui non mi farà
niente di male lo so perché è mio amico
intanto c'è una torcia abbastanza
luminoso ho fatto veramente bene sto
pezzo
intanto la torcia devo dire che
abbastanza luminosa quindi fatta bene
vabbè chissenefrega la grafica in si
giochi qua poi tra l'altro lasciamo
stare
ok c'è qualcosa qui dietro no bene
iniziamo subito raga non sappiamo come
siamo finiti qui dentro semplicemente
abbiamo sentito le storie brutte giusto
posto dobbiamo piazzare le telecamere
come si piazzano spento a perfetto visse
mica mi stavo pagando addosso spento io
la luce allora tasto è prima già fatta
prima telecamera ragazza vj paparazzo
c'è un barile ok c'è soltanto un barile
tranquilli tranquilli la madonna
ok ok ho perso
ho perso grande guinness world record
come gioco horror durato meno nei secoli
proprio vabbè rifacciamo syraka faccio
pensi videogames non sono bravo allora
c'è scritto voglio trovare asi prima che
voglio scoprire che cosa succede in
questo posto ecco cosa non avevo finito
di leggere piazza sei telecamere ok
vabbè ho capito basta
ok ragazzi siamo di nuovo andiamo di
questa volta che prima non ero entrato
nei sotterranei giustamente andiamo nei
sotterranei cambiamo un po strada allora
c'è non c'è niente
ci sono dei blocchi va bene ci sono
delle scarpe
porca [ __ ] c'è un foglio c'è un foglio
c'è un foglio c'è un foglio di merda
merda merda merda merda gigio di joe del
cazzo ok perfetto no no non è possibile
non ci voglio credere ok ho piazzato la
primate più schifo ma chi cazzo è pieno
di sa ma posso andare posso andare se ma
e sangue questo non si capisce non
voglio saperlo mi sembra di essere sul
titanic però non c'è proprio l'acqua
diciamo però che lasciamo stare
andiamo su cosa cosa devo devo andare
andiamo a sinistra meno fissa io non so
draga non so la posizione delle tele che
acqua dovevamo prima ok siamo a due
record record
raga ed è già una soddisfazione esser
arrivata a due bene devo andare a
sinistra destra a destra andiamo a
sinistra invece maledetto gg non è
possibile che mi spunti sempre ma perché
muoio ma perché muoio raga impossibile
non puoi vincere a sto gioco ti prende
allora porca [ __ ] se mi prende
un'altra volta stacco a si può corre a
ma si può correre non sapevo e vabbè ma
di tele ste cose
minchia ogni volta se cazzo di scatole
allora farmi mettere la telecamera che
mo spunta lo so lo sento
piano piano metti a 3 cup
metti la telecamera mettila 3com mettila
ok c'è la mamma perché mi prendi i colpi
se so già che spunta perché perché mi
prendo i colpi niente
raga non si può fare è impossibile mi
spunta gigio e mi ammazza subito non c'è
verso
e la quinta volta che ci riprovo non c'è
non si può non si può allora stavolta
[ __ ] ce la faccio non è possibile
che mi chiedevo morire ogni volta allora
piano piano un cazzo andiamo velocissimi
corro corro corro corro continuamente
sono sicuro che stavolta g giorno mi
fotte
anche perché sono morto cinque volte di
fila fate voi va bene andiamo di qua c'è
qualcosa qui no no non c'è niente
chelsea c'è una scala perfetto da lì ci
sono arrivato
ok devo andare non mi ricordo ok seconda
siamo a due
abbiamo eguagliato il record di prima
stavolta sono molto più deciso dalla
gassa volta non vince stavolta vinco io
maledetto gigio mi stai dietro si
sentono mi stai dietro mi stai davanti
però ma che cazzo ok ragazzi sono ho
scoperto che il personaggio principale
può fare tipo un salto alto 12 metri
cos'è quella roba lì credo che si vada
su va beh lasciamo stare
vabbè poche domande intanto c'è un coso
dove mettere la telecamera quindi
perfetto
me ne vado subito no niente niente
neanche andare in barca [ __ ] che
cos'è gigio freestyle
ok ci sia merda mi segue ma stavolta ce
la faccio forse stavolta ce la faccio
stava non ti girare spegne spegne la
luce ok no non spegniamo aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto
ok ok ok maledetto gg maledetto gg
no non l'ho [ __ ] niente niente non ci
riescono a circa raga
non ce la faccio impossibile è un gioco
assurdo non si può fare raga mi è venuta
un'idea sto provando a proseguire senza
accendere la torcia tipo in the rake
forse gigio non appare quando ok non
appare quando proverà proviamo ad andare
avanti senza accendere la luce tipo
direi che appunto noi invece appare
cazzo non appare ok ok niente
[Musica]
che cazzo ready cioè io sto morendo tipo
dieci volte di fila e tu ridi ma che
cazzo ridice raga io non ci ho parole
comunque non può essere così cioè non
possono averlo fatto così difficile è
una cosa impossibile
cioè come adesso a posto dietro perché
già mi ha accoltellato ma c'è guardate
la cosa assurda cioè non puoi correre
c'è poi correre manti prende lo stesso
che non c'è più miracolo non c'è più
non ci posso credere ok seconda
telecamera torno subito indietro a no ma
davanti ok cienaga due allora ok 333 non
ci crede 3 non ci posso credere non 5
allora assegnate data e ora perché è un
giorno da ricordare questo merda treno
non mi puoi uccidere adesso prodotto
strumento gigio gigio maledetto non mi
uccide rai adesso che sono a 3 ok
ok mi hai tirato un calcio da 444 raga
non si può fare
hanno fatto troppo difficile non so che
dirvi magari sbaglio io non lo so nuovo
esser di mouse e va bene pick up cosa
luigi tasti che praticamente non ancora
usato sono il babel mouse non ho capito
che cazzo se pick up cosa cioè cosa devo
prendere niente
e poi contro il per abbassarsi ma non
c'è nient'altro c'è boh non so se
sbaglio qualcosa io
vabbè c'è il tasti che non ancora
premuto sono tasto sinistro pick up però
non c'è niente da prendere quindi bono
ha capito cosa mi serve e poi e poi
niente questo incontro e per stare più
abbassati ma non serva un cazzo anche
questo cioè perché mai dovrei abbassarmi
non è che non mi abbasso non mi trova
credo però vabbè lasciamo stare che hai
stavolta nomi fatti più c'è c'è se
notate sul tavolino c'è la foto di jeff
the killer
ok allora non mi interessava a prenderla
sinceramente ci prova di nuovo raga
piano piano piano kay vai
[Musica]
vabbè raga basta non ne posso più io
direi che posso concludere qui secondo
me era gal hanno fatto troppo difficile
comunque se volete scaricarlo link lo
trovate nella descrizione come al solito
è va beh direi di chiudere a questo
punto servi dove è piaciuto lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci vedevano un
prossimo video si sicuro molto più lungo
di questo è bello ragazzi